our luck at ear Monday here's cider with
a good takeaway there Cider on the wing
for to Brink to Bret Waits and shoots and
the rebound going to the goal was rash mus
who got bumped in there by Sam laferty
more the offensive side for kingberg so
that'll help the maple Le end given away
there though save made by ball rebound
and he's got that one as cop let the shot go
wall juggled it but able to hang on there's
laferty slowed down by H bman get it
away big stop there by huso off NOA
Gregor uh corn crop isn't coming off
yet uh the hay is all off winter Wheats
being planted and uh soybeans maybe
but they got to get a first crust
pretty good shot by C right there pull snapped and
dragged and sna fir there off the post tribute to
Dan Long settles one back and gets
it across to Raymond pulls it goal
post wow cleared away but gosses faar's
got it again and a one-year free agent
deal with the Red Wings back for m
CIS the native of Plymouth Michigan
scores wow how happy is he probably with
friends and family here from Plymouth the
free agent signing last year who spent
last season with the Marley in the Big
10 Max Ellis take a look at this replay I don't
know if this going a stick or not it it really
eluded whoo uh it was is a knuckle ball and I
think it hit the defenseman stick and kind of
that knuckled it even worse and hit the bottom
of his catching glove back high slot that goes
off mat the brink it around to an open wing
for rash M back to goss's Bear perfect feet
in front and just wide by debret trying to go
back to Ras M and just didn't make it his way
in a change for both sides mitt play with Cam
Loops that would help us but also help the leap
so maybe torn a bit there here's Kyle Clifford
kept alive Miller scores it's squeak through
in front of the goal again was Max Ellis did
he get a piece of that we'll see but it's two
nothing Toronto it certainly hit somebody
in front of the net the cider were tied up
together H okay it hit cider's right leg
I don't know if it hit Ellis or not on the
after that no I don't think it did so if
not it would be Miller's goal but we'll
see given Miller the goal bounced in offsider
loose in front of the net popping a little too
deep couldn't Jam It Gos bear a shot that was
blocked into the middle it came but an outlet
here for Dylan Lin Lin up along with Fischer
and Pon who straddled the line to keep on side
Arin shot went off a maple leaf stick push back to
the line by Pon cider to sherro shot got blocked
Pon again in front off Lin pin balled again ball
the down the score maybe that's the break the Red
Wings needed it's two to one boy Buck about a game
of pinball holy mackerel off Lin skate off the
Toronto skate off the goalie pad then comes Fisher
into the middle of it Lin sticks in there bang
bang bang 200,000 points on that one and it's a
2-1 game it looked like lkin may have preached in
there with the hook on his blade and just sneakily
put it into the net yeah he it was Larin stick too
and he's up he's out High slop big save there by
whoo AAR a little more hustle little better on
the passes Toronto's been really out hustling him
so [Applause] far shro one tier scores it's a tie
game important sof [Applause]
draws brought to get a rocket away from the point
it's one timer yeah the go
cender has no chance to see
this looked like strong maybe in front of the
net it was yeah he's tied up by a
Toronto defenseman the [Applause]
goenda gos to Bear came in looks like a rugby
game yeah shot there by fiser cars BTO it's
3 to2 oh he [Applause] back that was a Rugby
scrum for about 30 seconds on the near board
spck bouncing all over the place and again a
quick shot through the defenseman stick and
leg and the goer walls probably going you got
to be kidding me really it's a bad break for
Toronto cuz it hit one of their own players from
the point and went right to Joe Baleno who had
his stick on the ice what's that tell you young
players always keep your stick on the ice and
Baleno and two years later 65 points 52
assists both career high downstairs by
looking at a replay before we get it
whether it was a stick or a puck or a
glove or something made the pass there to
a Brink it did L and R the goal good save
by wall I think he lost control of the
puck T when he went to the back end his
countryman Haron Raymond penalty expiring
in a couple of seconds Patriot to Raymond
hit a stick penalty over wrong fires scar
we told you he's got a great [Music] shot
I heard the goal f it was close to the bar
but basically just came to tab hands with
everybody was like oh oh man you believe
that like it found a way in oh my that's
a heck of a shot oh for sure for the
native of Amsterdam yeah who had 21
goals last [Music] [Applause] season no Gregor
bu in front all alone hurg stopped BYO wman
Fisher wide open oh what a save wall got over
without the stick desperation and he made the
stop on Christian Fisher RS live coming your
way a week from tonight for a whole cast of
characters Le character I believe John Keon
here's Raymond in what a save most of the
times a play like this you're not getting in but
he did catch the theaf defenseman a little bit
off stride and then took advantage of that
and got himself a pretty darn good scoring
chance of that just on side at the line
for Mitt back in front knocked away ABY
kenin ABY again in front the score
lery power play goal and six on [Applause]
four Leafs one for four on the power
[Music] play lot of bodies down there mostly
white jersey Robertson stays with it three
seconds left one last shot Mitten across
the shot knocked down the game is [Music]
over